IN POLITICS , TEOORITICIZE TRUM
POLITICAL TA EDEL DIVIDING HER
UNCLE,TE, AN INSNC
FAED BY HIS
INABILITY TO SD HIMSELF.
AUTHOR OTHNEW BOOK "THRECKONING
AND NDING A WAY TO
RY M
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK, PEG
AN UOSE AN
E, FMER ENT. AND VIEW OF YOUR
PSHOE O YOU SEE
POLITICAL PSYCHE?
HE
UNFORTUNATELK PRCI OSNGS HE
DID TO US AS A COUNTRY IDIVIDE
US.
FROE GI
E MADE THINGS D TO BE EDH SE THV
EVEN W
ELECTION WE LOST
DECISIVELY TO BIE AR,
WAS THAT THE ELECTION HAD
BEEN STOLEN, THEREBY UNDERMINI F
ELECTIONS IN ACA IA WAY N'T THI
F SE
OF THE FALLORO, AND WERSENIND L
ENRESH
THE EXNT HO DO.OW DO TH UNC LIK
W?EEN BANNED OMAJOR SOCIALFORMS.
THSEE BILL AND GETTT'T JUST HOLP
T  STRONG BIPARTISAN
VOTE IN THE SENATE EVEN THOUGH
TRUMP WAS OUT THERNDES AGAINST
WITH THIS?NOW, ISO WAYS I
THINK HE'S S ENOUGH COPHANTS ANE
AT.
PLUS, OF COURSE, REPUBLICANS ARM
S RING.NTINUE TOL TO S
SO, ALTHOUGH, YES, I'M SURE HE'S
FEELING THE STING  HAVINE POWERE
T
HE'SNGO N FOT IN
>> IF HA T
IN NOVEMBE DECEMBER I WOULD
HAVE SAI NO BECAUSE
BEDOT  W
AGAIN.
BUM E KEEPG  WITH STUFF.
REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO  T.
TING
SER  THE INSURRECTION WAS G THA
PERPETRATED ORT IT WAST
THAT BIG A
T SOMEBODY WHO'S GOTT
WH INSUTI OWNVERNMENT.
PLWE HAVE HUNDREDS O
SUPPRESSIOS BEING ED ALMOSY STA
STHER, THE
SO IF DONALD GET TNT,
ASSUMING HE'S STILL A EE FEELS
LOSE, WHY WOULDN'T HE RUN?
SOMETLD
ST FF US>> SO IN YOUNEOKYO
MAA AT WORLD
THAT YOUR UNCL WATES S
A AND WAS UNABLE T
ECTIVELY.
QUOTE, DONALD'ONALLY LACKEEMTH
STEMMED FROM HISEICIWEAKNESS,
UNQUOTE.
EXPLAIN WHY YOU THINK HAVI UNCLH
COVID PANDEMICT YEAR
OF I EXACERBATED NOT JUST THE
EXPERIENCED AS A RESULT OF
THEMIC. WELL,ALL,
FAILING INITIALLY
OUGH THEN,AIN, BECSED DOESN'T  C
HERE ENG,T WOULD'VE
RE TO
OKAY, WE MISJUDGED THI NE O SAY,
NEED TO TRY SOMETHING ELSE.
TOULD HAVE MEANT ADMIRONG, WHICT
SANOMY OR SAVINGVE
NC THE